歡迎收看 最佛心幽默的財經節目
理財達人秀 我是李肇華
好 今天到底散戶 大戶在做什麼呢
因為今天的成交量呢
是真的比較冷清一點
上市加上上櫃都還不到一兆元
今天看到三大法人的買賣超
也都非常的微服喔
好 台股漲到這裡
事實上我們的位階跟全世界比起來
算是很厲害的喔
我們在等韓股 我們在等廢半
但是昨天其實美國有出手喔
他並不希望美國的公債值利率
一直跑上去
造成講的科技大廠的負債壓力山大
所以財政部決定出手買公債
把值利率給壓下來
其實這對整體的環境
絕對是一個正向表列喔
雖然今天的盤看起來略微平淡
但後面隱藏了非常多的布局跟大事
等一下我們來賓會就自己看好的產業
因為這段時間長到這裡稍微休息
其實是選股最好的時機點
如果喜歡產業的
如果喜歡籌碼的
今天都有非常詳細的分享
話不多說先來歡迎三位來賓
第一位是骨科大夫
龍醫生Eason
好Eason也要講美國財政部出手了
為什麼要救公債
就是希望能夠平息這一場的債務風波
要的還是所有的 AI 股回到正常的軌道上面
所以等一下 Yseng 會告訴你
接下來到底誰會接棒台股往上攻
雖然這兩天有一點點微微的回檔
但最近的情況應該說
這兩年的情況回檔都不容易太深
所以第一個我們先看機器人
雖然展覽好像快結束了
但 Yseng 說這是一個中長線話題
等一下會告訴你
而且相較之下
位階比較低 獲利卻在往上走
非常急劇潛力
另外一個就是CPU了
CPU絕對有領頭羊代表
但位階已經太高了
今天Eason告訴您
他幫您找到的是
中低位階很有潛力的CPU
一定要停起來
第二位是我們的破斷
當中雙刀流高謝榮
好謝榮今天也要講了
到底現在大戶在做什麼
等一下會有一個獨家的教學
大戶都在買電力股
到底為什麼兩週三週這樣買
而且還沒有全面發動
絕對是潛力
另外海力士又來了
海力士這一次砸下了
將近台幣1兆元要來救市
上一次才砸
1億元
整個市場就反轉了
這次砸1兆元
到底記憶體要走到哪裡去
等一下將您買
第三位我們好久不見的產業隊長張傑
看到隊長
我們就對產業的前景有信心
什麼東西有信心呢
他提早帶我們去看9月的半導體展
特別最近傳出來的
CoAOS爆單
真的爆單
等一下告訴您會爆在哪一些產業上面
台積電扶植本土供應鏈
絕對不容小去
升級 爆單加上
現在說Intel也要來幫忙
好 不管Intel跟台積電是近是和
有人是雙吃又寡戰
兩邊訂單都能收
等一下聽隊長講清楚了
好 首先有請谷克代夫
今天台股真的是膠頭比較冷清
冷清我們就冷靜一下
冷靜下來看什麼呢
美國出手了啦
他要買很多的公債
所以直立率就下去了
下去感覺上每一股就比較質問了
我們台股世界強
我們在月線上面
那機器人的話
Ginety要IPO了
雖然今天雨數跌了17%
但你覺得中長線看好
CPU幫我們找低位接的
那今天亮的呢又不到8000億
所以這種盤大家絕對不要去最高殺低
因為量縮
那就是進入到一個盤整的格局
而且最近的利空反應的都是
之前的一個延續性
包括通膨
包括在拆槓桿等等
那在這兩天又出來一個美債的利空
30年債的這個利率是創下
大概2000年以來的新高
可是10年債還沒
10年債其實他的高檔是在這一次
暴力升息大概快到5%
那其實10年債
並沒有很明顯的一個反應
所以我覺得其實這一次的
30年債呢
其實大家也沒事不會去注意到
他 那我覺得有點這個又是在
小作文要去這個打壓股市
或是有一些刻意的一些話題
那不過呢 昨天貝森特又出手了
他把購債的金額
再double來到四十億美金了
所以可以看到債券的
這個常債值利率又往下掉了
包括川普也taco了
那本來跟伊朗看起來談判談不攏
那可是他又說可能又會某個時間點
可能商鋪又會去恢復談判了
所以其實在整個政治面
或是在利率來說
相對可能會影響到選情
所以把利率同盟壓抑在一個另一程度
當然我覺得這個是對於
美方來說相對來著重要
所以FED的這個升息
我覺得9月這一次
應該還是會暗兵不動
緊接著是8月26號
揮達財報要登場
美國時間8月26號
就是台灣的8月27號
那預估第二季營收
應該有機會達到940到950億美元
美元第三季 下一個季度
可以再達到破千億了
那現在其實有一些雜音出來認為說
是不是風險過高
然後融資的金額過大等等
就是灰打變成全球AI債主
會不會太危險
那美營反而是認為
現在因為在自由現金流量
所計算的方式 有些不太一樣
那反而是市場上有一些定價
是太過於擔憂了
甚至他認為潛在的漲幅
可能有超過五成
他的本益比像跟台積電一樣
都是已經比較偏低的
這種大型股的部分
如果本益比偏低的話
其實未來應該有機會
如果資金再回流的話
是有機會再做一個反應的
所以指數我認為今年
還是有機會上五萬點
隨著時間我要推進了
外資開始會用明年的EPS
去計算台積電的一個合理的價格
所以我們看在指數
硬是回到月線左右的一個附近
就沒有再破滴
那1 2 3 4 5
5天之前跟大家說
4萬6到4萬8這邊是空方的一個壓力區
套牢區這邊沒有那麼容易過
對這邊有一個套牢區
那上次也說不會打第二隻腳打那麼深
4萬2之下如果真的回來的話
我覺得這反而不能買
為什麼大
對不能打那麼深
頂多是對稱這邊的一個左肩
頂多在這裡
因為大家仔細看
4萬4到4萬6這一段
外資買了一大堆
台幣也升值
法人也買
外資都在買
投信比較沒有在買
那主要外資買了這個不少
可是這一段的融資是縮手的
有沒有看到這大概
對 融資越來越不敢進場
融資進場是在4萬2到4萬4這一段
所以外資除了在台積電漲停這一天之外
後面他在這邊是連買的這一段
所以如果這個地方都被跌破花
連法人都會套了
那這個就不得了
所以
所以我說如果真的破4萬2的話
反而是不能買的
會有賣壓出來是不是
對 那我認為不會跌到那麼深
因為
如果真的台股再回來4萬之下
廢半跟韓股可能都要破低了
因為我們現在在等他們嘛
所以我覺得應該不會了
大概頂多就是月線這邊上下做個震盪
那等待籌碼穩定之後
再醞釀下一次的攻擊
總歸以上大概是卡在4萬4
到4萬6
這個區間做一個震盪
那等待再回答的一個法說
後面圈之故有沒有再推升的力道
其實維台我們以前也聊過
盤整盤散戶是厲害的
對 很會低買高賣
很會低買高賣
可是趨勢一出來大家要注意
是不是開始被
咬或者是賣錯邊
沒錯 這很有趣的現象
我們來快速掃一下
今天盤面上的重點
有幾個領域的領頭羊
那台積電的話
撐在這裡算蠻強的
這一根漲停板過後
除了這一天之外
那基本上都守在這根掌鈴板的開盤架位置
就這個跳高缺口基本上都還有守住
所以真的還蠻強勢
那也把指數撐在這個位階
那另外在PCB部分
下游長多ABF部分開始休息
那現在換上游開始在漲
包括這幾天日東訪股價
也從低檔開始有一些在做表態
所以副橋今天盤中一度拉出掌庭
不過今天這個量報的一些大
這個後續可能看一下盤後的籌碼
是誰丟出來的
不過他也委屈相當長的時間
破肩部
對 真的這個第二季幾乎都沒有他的戲份
都沒有表現
那國劇化呢
今天因為98EA
先賣了50張
沒有全賣啦
賣50張
但是賣大家就很緊張
這當然
要力挺他耶
對 姚思基姆是一個指標
那我覺得手上還是有被動的朋友
這邊要等籌碼乾淨了
因為主動師也開始有一些
一貼補去做出場
所以被動這個地方要再利息反彈的機會不大
但是我覺得要破底機會也不太大了
可是你這個地方如果資金再耗在這裡的話
可能就要等待可能一個月兩個月比較久的一個時間
那等到下一波醞釀的一個上空
包括日韓的被動最近也都是比較偏弱勢的
這可能要跟著國際的一些龍頭去走
所以被動我覺得持有的就先擺著
那等到真的有急漲或反彈的時候去調節一些些
那另外在今天軍工類股
漢祥早盤一度也繞到漲停
不過雷虎沒什麼反應
那軍工我覺得重頭戲
還是要等月底那個軍構
到底表決狀況是如何
所以這幾天我覺得
可能都還是有一些
電檔演出的現象
其實算想是
真的是在等
然後或者是資金幣封港這樣子
對 就是電子不太行的時候
資金就會過來一下
所以要買軍工呢
這個因為月底有一個關鍵的事件
所以要買可能還是等拉回
不要在這個漲停
或者是大漲的時候衝進去
因為我覺得
真正重要還是在月底這個狀況
當然事件性是有可能一翻兩瞪眼的
所以如果有比較低檔的布局
至少翻如果不是好的時候
不會受傷太重
那再來就是在機器人
看起來是這一波資金
有進去做卡位的一個重點
那輝達也點名了16個台廠
要物理AI的部分
未來是一個趨勢
那包括這些的
這個指標大家可以開箱
大部分都老朋友
像什麼這個炎華索羅門
廣運啊 達明啊 對不對
那所以台灣也有新的AI十大建設
總預算406億
雖然說不算太多
但是也是每一年有在做一個增加
增加當中
那包括昨天雨素呢
IPO了
到昨天最高價
雖然說他昨天一開盤就是最高價了
好誇張聽說他們有那種私底下黃牛交易票
就是買雨素這樣子
不過今天他們有提到說
人心機械人還沒有那麼快
所以今天是有下跌
對 所以盤中就有些掉下來
不過這個也是表示說
市場對於這個題材非常的熱門
抽中的話一張大概賺兩百萬台幣
那在這個包括九月密集也有
Gerlity也要準備IPO了
那從這個二十五億估值
上看一百五十億美元
同樣也是一個這個
超乎原本預期的這樣的金額
那接下來還有在這個
芝加哥也有在相關的這個自動化展
所以我認為機器人的這個題材
接下來是蠻多的 還有延續性
那所以在工具機或機器人這一塊
我認為在機密機械算是首選
機密機械
那包括在日元走生的狀況下
那台廠也是相對比較有利
競爭關係
然後另外題材就剛剛提到還有延續性
那這邊可以看到很整齊
就是最近一個月的
機器人這一個區塊
幾乎都是主力是站在買方的
那所以看起來資金是有往這個區域來的機軸
包括他們的一個大戶
也都相對來得其中
好在2049的上銀
我們的大廠上銀
上銀最近外資有在做一個聯賣
那第二季EPS 2.4上半年4塊錢
那外資這幾天也有發報告
那目標價基本上都在四字頭之上
所以上銀可不可以穩住在400支上
我覺得相對來得重要
那所以現在這個未接大陸的操作的話呢
400之下建議計量第一階
因為靠近400看起來這邊
好幾次的這個壓力
都有盤中去做測試
它沒有能夠越過
所以如果現在亮縮的一個環境
要去做佈局的話呢
可能等到盤中的一個低檔
或者是有下來的時候
再去做個第一階
那要不一個做法就是
你等到真正突破400之後
再找機會去介入
也就站穩400之後
等他突破
對 站穩400之後
其實應該還有一個波段的
這個走勢 大概這兩種做法
那包括頭線開始在做一個進場
頭線很可愛喔
這也是981
買了以後就兩天賣掉
不過現在是連買了三天
看來比較有點延續性了
對 所以組裝師也是
隨著他的心情去買跟賣
加油 希望連買
對 看好未來在機器人的一個題材
那本業部分工具機
就是已經開始穩下來了
那盟利部分呢
這邊越線機身 礦薪高後壓回
對 機器人有集檔有創新高
一檔是索羅門 蒙利是另外一檔
那第二季跟這個上半的EPS
看起來或許還
好像喔
不是這麼的 不是那麼好看
可是外資也在做一個聯買
包括投信是進場之後都沒有出
那包括9月還有一個台股的半導體廠
等一下隊長會講
所以他的這個題材
可以說是可以延續到9月
雙題材
那包括他也跟這個
金人代工的這個龍頭跟風車大廠
積極去擴建先進封裝的一個產能
先進封裝
這也是一個話題上全部包在一起
旗下的這個蒙鷹科技也切入在
機械人的這個關節減速器的這個零件
所以可以注意月線這邊的支撐
是
因為這個族群確實是大戶法人有在聚集的
那另外一個族群我想
這個四彩窩朋友很喜歡就是 CPO
先疊先紙疊之外
大力光快要重返榮耀囉
是
歷史高點 6075 快過了
那如果還原權息應該就過了
那我覺得大立光除了CPO
他還有在蘋果這個題材
馬上蘋果新機要上市
那包含未來鏡頭的用量越來越多
那你會買遮疊嗎
應該會 可是蘋果的系統
用不用的習慣要再試驗
那CPO的這個量產
這個就是真實系統
灰達也有這樣子一個量產器的交換
包括今年的800G在未來的1.6T
去升級 以及光鏡同退成為一個共識
所以CPU是最近進駐的一個標的
指標可以看大力光的一個表現
那現在的話認為呢
因為位階有些比較偏高
從低點可能都翻倍了
或者已經漲了五六成以上
或是回星高點那個附近了
那這種位階比較偏高的
可能要稍微等拉回一下
連亞好猛喔
再去做一個佈局
那如果中位階或者是這個低位階的話
我覺得可以先介入
或者先去買一半左右的這個持股
也是可以的
華星光沿著月線往上做一個墊高
外資最近也是買多賣比較少
包括這裡面每一股的CPU都是重衰
可是它的大客戶賣威爾
昨天股價卻是在往上漲
因為你跟谷歌要進一步合作
所以它也是跟著賣威爾吃香喝辣
包括在AI資料中心的光收發模組
那以及未來800G的產品開始放量
所以其實可以注意這邊也打出一個底型之後
事實上都在開始慢慢的底底高往上走高
另外在25全新
全新是接近前面第二季的高檔
其實他算很強勢反彈的
那位階稍微比較高一些些
那也在一個多頭排列向上
那可以看到這一個跳高缺口一直都沒有被回補
那基本上補下都在這裡上上下下
那因為其實最近的台股很容易跳上跳下
因為量縮的關係
所以如果布局同樣是等到相對
這個平台位階低檔的時候
再去做一個布局比較好
那它這個轉型方向也要往零化音的
這樣子一個題材去做轉型
那所以呢在
這個零化音基板供應商擴產狀況下
應該有機會在後續的一個
這個有對它的營收有幫助
其實CPU說廣也蠻多廠商的
這個算強勢的
等壓回也不用太擔心
因為零化音真的超級缺
那剛剛華星光就是反彈到一半
相對他可能後面反彈的幅度
還會比較合理的
所以CPU目前的話
可能中低位些的是率先去做布局
會比較好
好這邊非常謝謝Eason
謝謝
Eason非常清晰的說明
就算要打腳
也不能再往下打太深
因為這一波上來
台幣升值外資買
買在這個4萬2 4萬4都有
所以這一段如果是被套牢的
那跌下去吐出來那就不得了
當然希望這件事情不要發生
我們台股現在就是相對強
在等費辦 在等南韓跟上來
好 在這樣的情況下
我們也可以看一下市場上的
法人大戶在做什麼呢
ㄟ 集氣人
其實這個之前現場又有提到
現在確實資金在聚集
而且不是只有展覽的題材
絕對是一個未來
長線可以布局的
而 CPO 高位階代表什麼
代表領頭洋已經有人
非常認同這個族群了
中低位階遲早補漲
然後我們也可以看一下
他的大客戶和他的貨利
飲收的狀況給您做參考
好廣告回來
謝龍要上場了
一樣剛剛延續的
大戶在幹嘛呢
其實大戶真的是默默兩三週
都在買所謂的電力鼓
不要因為他沒有長
就放棄免得後面噴漲
我們會來不及
至於機體
我們有全世界最強的南亞科
衛階在這
那其他的顆粒廠
要不要趕快跟上來呢
為什麼一直說納瓦克世界強
因為他在創歷史新高
但是其他的世界大廠都沒有
到底新高還有一點距離
到底我們的科立場厲害在哪裡
但也不能只有納瓦克
這邊來請教現榮
華邦電雷 立即電雷
其他漢人雷
通通給我踹共
記憶體科立場
到底要不要全部跟上
今天要教我們
到底你是怎麼抓大戶的
大戶連續兩三週都在買電力股
好 那第一個
先來看一下記憶體
這兩天最重要的大事
就是海利市
砸了40兆含元
40兆含元是多少
大概換算台幣9200億
美金是288億
那這個金額
大家發現到
大概就是海利市跑去美國發ADR
他用增資薪股的方式
募集了265億的現金
結果這265億
大家發現
你募集了私金之後
把股權稀釋了
所以原始股東不爽
現在呢
這260幾億的資金
全部用買庫場股
然後呢
買了2400萬股
就把它注消掉
等於說海力士這個ADR
本來稀釋股權的效應
大概這個部分就被他抵消掉
所以看到今天三星的股價
漲了9.4%
重點是海力士大漲了12.7%
跟這個買庫場股
或有比較大的關係在的
不錯
我覺得他們現在對於股市的想法
有在進步
要不然我們都覺得
南韓不會做股票
對 現在這地方
他開始有改進
之前發現
增資大家這個供給增加
現在是把供給剪掉
這地方股票減少了
股價就漲上去了
那當然還有一個關鍵
就是川普政府現在施壓蘋果
不要去買中國的記憶體
那這個部分其實
也跟現在整個記憶體
多空達倫戰
看空的都覺得說
第一個這地方第二季財報大賺的時候
景氣是不是就達到高崩
所以獲利數字公佈出來
很多人看到股價都是開高走低
反手賣出
另外一個基本面大家最擔心的就是
韓國跟中國都在大幅度擴充產能
尤其中國擴產的速度非常的快
認為說未來供給會大幅度增加
但是如果說中國擴充的產能
現在這個地方川普不準
蘋果去買不準
在這地方 規達去買
等於說進不了美國為主的國際市場的話
就算新產能開出來
對全球的記憶體的供給增加
這個部分影響就會降到最低
那在這個地方 我這個看法
目前記憶體多空大論戰
看空的剛才講了
第二季的獲利大賬
會不會是代表景氣達到高峰
以及未來的供給會大幅度增加
那供給的部分剛才提到
中國的新產能有川普幫大家擋著
進不了國際市場影響降到最低之外
更重要的是
大家都只看到供給會增加
忽略了一件事情
就是目前AI市場
對於整個記憶體的需求
還在持續的增加
目前公幣應求的局面
其實這地方都還有
這個繼續擴大的現象
換句話說 證據在哪裡
就在記憶體的現貨報價
還在持續上漲
目前DDRFY已經漲到了53美金
DDRFY的部分
更是突破了90美金
數字會說話
代表說記憶體真的爆價還在上漲
公併球並沒有扭轉
所以第二季的獲利
會不會就是達到高峰呢
這個目前來看
記憶體製造這一塊
下半年這個獲利還會持續盤高
景氣還是沒有達到高峰的現象
我認為第三季獲利
還是會繼續上去的
其實這邊有一條很有趣
標虎去調升了美光的債務評級
變成Tubal B的Proth
這個在網上一集
它又可以變成A的minus
他以後發債的成本會降低很多
這根本就是全面來相助
所以這個部分
美光現在賺到錢
如果說未來要發債
成本又能夠降低的話
我想整個機器的評價還是有機會
進一步的再來做拉高
所以關鍵來了
股價的部分
當然南亞科這個地方看到
8月份以來
外資投信都是在地方同步繼續賣
400張大戶
臨去兩周又增持下去
所以股價的部分
現在已經這地方
正如我們上次說的
很有機會再創歷史新高
所以全球記憶體股價
之前跌到歪的時候
他拉回
現在大盤
其他記憶體股只是反彈
他已經率先創了歷史新高
那只是創新高
我們常常講
他的股信的地方會發現
這個五月五號
發動一波公視
過高就拉回
過高就會拉回
所以每次都不要在這個過高的時候
急著就去搶
那拉回來
我覺得這地方再來找買點會是比較適合
所以技術面的部分我們就觀察
8月7號這裡有一個這地方十字線
振蕩我們做股票的操作策略
就是先找支撐
支撐這地方能夠找到
拉回來支撐不破的時候
是不是就有機會繼續往上推進上去
那我覺得說南亞科的部分
這個還是記憶體的首選
上半年EPS賺了23塊
但不是最高峰
下半年我覺得還是有繼續
這個地方走高的機會
再來看華邦電的部分
華邦電的地方這個股價
看到說最近又開始橫盤整理
他比較吃虧一點就是
營收比重目前D-RAM
大概佔了53%
Flash也有31%
邏輯IC則是佔13%左右
最近的操作你會看到
股價的地方反彈上來
但是這裡看到7月6號的時候
股價跌下來反彈
這裡有個高點
那這次反彈上來高點
也大概都落在200塊左右的位置
所以目前股價大概還在這個位置
正當整理為主
但是低檔支撐
8月5號這個多方缺口
目前來看
收的也都相當的穩
大概在157.5到164.5之間
這裡我覺得
也可以收得住
也沒有太大問題
還是有機會在這個守住支撐之下
至少維持一個區間操作的模式
是可以的
因為我剛剛一看就說
怎麼這麼弱
然後現容就說哪有弱還好
至少站上了軍線
都站上軍線了是好轉的一個形式
那當然一個族群大家最關心的就是
這地方上游科理目前來看都還是很強
甚至像金豪科有創歷史新高
那很多人關心的是
模組廠的部分群聯遺頂微剛
怎麼這個地方
這個股價最近像群聯公佈出來
上倍能EPS187塊股價又跌了
最近這地方外資投薪的部分
還是在8月份持續的慢
那400張大戶其實注意到
開始有這地方
連兩周增持
一定也有郵件轉正的現象
看他群聯的部分
最近提到這地方
200張大戶開始有低檔
慢慢的再做增持了
只是最近外資還在調節
賣最多就是公布財報
賺了187塊的一天
開高走低下來
但是形態上面會不會變成說
現在左肩出來 底部出來
這次拉回來
如果守住了半年線這個地方
做一個右肩
那這個就可以觀察一下
以左肩的位置大概在168.5
在這個地方做一個對稱的話
拉回來這個左肩能夠守得住
接下來股價就有機會
那至短線上
因為8月14號就是公佈財報出來
上半年賺187塊那天的AK
那這個太醜了一點
所以股價如果說要正式的轉強
大概那天的高點要先過著去
如果過著去突破景線
我們講一個投奸底的形態
就有機會出來
股價就有一個最喜歡
開始發動公司的機會了
獲利真的很好
但是說實話
去年也漲到過2880
也不是沒有漲
現在感覺上
就是他的獲利
跟市場的籌碼
跟認同度
要達到一個平衡
才有辦法再攻
要不然明明獲利
其實挑不出毛病來
那關鍵
如果說第三季
營收持續創高
到時候第三季獲利
會不會又比第二季來得更好
化解了大家擔心
第二季見到高峰疑慮
大概就是股價發動公司的時刻了
因為潘董到處跑
有點餘心不忍了
是 怎麼法人不買單呢
所以我們等近代一下
第三季的一個狀態
對 好那當然記憶體的部分
我們說目前還是以顆粒為主
但是模組廠也不用
這個地方太過於悲觀
那這個這是上之前講的
七月三十號講的
臺灣電腦創下歷史新高
最近有回檔到這個
往下回檔了一下
對 所以這邊的話
還是持續看好
把通波機板類的
感覺上都已經創高了
市場的共識蠻高的
對 均線也是一個標準多頭排列
回測一下這個地方
這個十日線 好像今天也有收下銀線
所以目前這組股價
還是維持多頭的結構
那只要這地方之前
這裡有一個黑K 黑K完
又再度過高
通常就是洗完盤繼續再攻
這個低點不要去跌破
大概這個攻擊結構
還是會維持下去
那雙紅的部分
最近股價又拉回了
那因為我們之前是在這個
剛好最低點那天810塊
跟大家介紹的
果然公佈出來營收創新高收
一波急漲了大概兩成多的幅度
那最近也稍微做個拉回
但是我們觀察到下半年Gb300
我們說過追加的訂單
已經開始這個出現
所以營收7月份也創歷史新高
第二季這個地方
新舊產品的一個交換期
大概結束之後
下半年的動能會開始加速
所以我覺得股價應該沒有問題
還是有機會繼續再上到
雙紅是散熱裡面
比較明顯弱厚的
要不要換到齊鴻
或是要不要換到最近大復活的監測
如果說想要在地方追求
快速能夠創新高的股票
齊鴻監測可能會快一點
對 心態比較強
那如果說有耐心
我們選低檔布局雙紅
我覺得還是可以繼續關注
安全可能比較安全
沒有大漲這樣子
沒錯
那當然接下來去觀察
大戶的一個動向的部分
那大戶動向怎麼去觀察
我們常常說
這個做股票
好像這個帶兵作戰孫子兵法說
知己知彼才能擺這樣不大
那我們是怎麼樣去知己知彼
看大盤 我們會去看
量能跟籌碼來觀察
大戶 散戶
現在在想些什麼
而且通常要反市場操作
就是量如果都1.5兆 1.6兆
全市場最FORMOR的時候
你反而要冷靜一點
那等到這地方
大家開始不敢買股票了
融資在大減
然後反而又是減便宜的時刻
所以大盤我們通常會建議大家
反市場操作是一個很重要的原則
那個股的部分呢
我們又要觀察
每個禮拜法人的動作 大戶的動作
那通常我會去觀察
400張的大戶有沒有
連續兩周增加的現象
因為如果說只看單週
比較容易碰到短線
隔日充大戶 隔週充大戶
只禮拜五買了
禮拜一就要買的狀況
所以兩個禮拜是確定一下
大戶真的有比較積極的
才做一個波端的佈局
那我們就站在巨人的肩膀上
不是說要去吃個豆腐什麼的
是用大戶的視角
來看看大戶現在在看什麼族群
說每個禮拜都是把大戶
這個400張大戶
有連續增加的股票挑出來之後
再去分類
大概哪一些是最近大戶
比較積極在進攻的一個族群
來選定未來的方向
那像最近就發現到
整個這個電力族群的部分
從上游這地方
光寶科做電源供應器的
BBU的AESKY跟新生力
到成吉很久的重電股化
最近這地方
大戶又有這地方
連續兩週三週再增持的現象了
重念股大戶會不會
都沒有戰鬥品益
那這個部分我們就先來看一下
第一個當然光寶科的部分
是大概最近大家最熱門的
200 400張大戶連續增持
股價已經在地方悄悄的創了
新高286.5
那也會發現到大戶現在進場的時候
本益比很重要
像本益比高的台達電
大戶就還在一直慢
那本益比低的光寶科
反而成為重點
股價當然創新高
如果說不想急著追
就拉回來觀察一下
8月5號這裡有個大量
這個作為一個洗盤
洗盤的低點
如果說能夠去
這個守得住24期不要破
股價還是有機會繼續走高
那如果說
這已經創新高不想追
剛才講到重電股的部分
最近好像這個地方
開始有加溫了
我們要相信大戶
因為剛剛講一個事情很重要
光寶科其實也盤很久
那北京比相對合理
還是發動了
不動就一動就創新高
中心店 到底
看到這個地方
這個最近是外資有在做加持
其實外資在買的時候
400張大幅是連續兩周
才做一個增加
一些幅度還滿明顯的
那上半年EPS賺了4.5塊
這是創歷史新高的
法人估計今年保守一點
8塊7到9塊
明年已經有人估到12到15塊
所以本利比算一算
這個如果說
就從今年9塊來上18倍而已
也不貴
如果明年大幅度成長到12到15塊
我覺得最近大戶應該是開始卡位
這一塊是不是這地方
當AI算力的瓶頸開始轉移到
電力瓶頸的時候
估價我覺得是
可能有加溫上去的機會了
因為真的該表態的原因是
可能用今年來看
前面到200塊這邊的時候
大家還覺得還好
可是已經到了8月下旬了
明年如果會成長
現在是台積電設備供應鏈
對啊
那現在看起來
確實就來到一個真的
叫做評價非常合理的階段了
沒錯
可能就是在等那個發動點
重點真的好久好久沒有發動了
尤其是他已經確認
是接到他一連訂單了
對 所以這個部分
達入到台積電供應鏈
做一個加持
會不會接下來成為股價發動點
我覺得投資朋友
都可以在未來墨加觀察
非常謝謝憲榮
謝謝
剛剛憲榮有講了一下
海力市的神奇操作
本來擴充了股本
現在又注銷了股本
反而讓股價往上走
但無論如何以顆粒來說
第三季的報價往上揚
這件事情
是可以確定的
模組廠
他就是在等一個獲利非常好
可是因為擔心他們的毛利率被侵蝕
但股價也修正了
所謂的平衡點
法人能不能得到一個認同的轉折
這邊也是可以來做期待的
至於剛剛講到的電力
光寶可是一個很好的例子
我們之前常常說
怎麼樣那麼牛啊
大壺買不動
可是現在創高啦
所以重電族群
也有台一電設備相關供應的
是不是現在大戶增持之後
未來能夠發動本益比超級低的
我們值得做期待
廣告回來
隊長要上場了
隊長好久不見
他來聊一下
9月就有半到地戰了
尤其最近有一個消息
COLOS已經爆單了
真的爆單了
台廠供應鏈
到底誰能吃到這些單
而且就算Intel加進來
兩邊的單都有吃的
寡戰廠商又是誰呢
好 為什麼臺灣現在在全球股市上面的表現
相當的強呢
就是我們整體的半導體供應鏈
真的很厲害啦
這個大概已經說破嘴
也很難形容
但是沒有關係
我們今天有隊長
9月就有一個半導體展
是非常盛大的展覽
那最近我們都知道先進封裝
真的叫全面報單
還說intel要加進來一起幫忙
這怎麼回事
那這邊的話呢
我們就先進封裝
幫忙這怎麼回事
那這邊的話呢
除了三檔小台積
這個小台積裡面
還包含了
可能橫跨到兩邊的單都能吃
是的
那我想最近大家
其實在反彈上來之後
看法其實我們剛剛這個
休息在聊天
有打腳派的嘛
也有盤整派
也有直接公高派的啦
那我想直接公高
其實有可能就是要看半導體
因為有一些這個長多的
他其實還沒恢復元氣
籌碼比較亂
所以接下來這段時間呢
因為你太久沒有來對李玉你是不是
製作單位說要金句
金句他就順便放了這個
林志穎的照片出去
他有看到
他說創新高是最強
這是我自己的金句
那長最多就是主流
因為其實接下來是
這一段時間大家找不到主流
例如說這個被動元件
有一些可能從一千多塊
那跌回五六百
長到七百
其實距離新高還有一段
那有一些其實創高
例如說南亞科有創高
可是有些模組廠其實沒有
他們比較稱之不起
那比較整齊的可能就是這個ABF
那剩下就是半導體
所以我覺得大家其實
如果你是打腳派或是盤整派
那倒不如選股不選市
那就找最安心的半導體
所以半導體還是我們最大的一個靠山
那不論是在這個9月1號 2號
這個Semi-Comp
這個聚焦三個主軸
先跟大家講
第一個
如果半導體蓬勃發展
貪污會很大
對
OK 那爆發式的規模整長
那台灣又是這個所謂的多重產業的堆疊
讓整個AI重新定價台股
那這個時候講話就要大聲必須要說
我們的GDP
這個第一季15%
我來第二季12%
全年這個主計處估計
11%是全世界第一名
你要大聲講出來啊
這改得一定啊
所以原則上呢
多重產業的堆疊
造成所謂的重新定價台股
這個台股世界最強
很合理啊
因為股市是經濟的儲窗嘛
好 那三個重點我們今天只抓一個啦
就是說這個先進製程我覺得會是重點
那當然 AI 基礎設施
因為其實我其實說不懂啦
因為你從三年前大家就在講
OEM 廣達 維穎 維創 紅海 人塑
這個河塑 神達什麼的
全部能組裝的
那說這些
不要說老什麼啦
就是老的新的
這個大家也都知道啦
我覺得會重點或是在這個
那記憶體剛剛這個有這個先進已經有講過了嘛
所以我覺得這個也當然也是重點
所以兩個都重點
那我們今天只挑一個就是說
我覺得先進製程的一個狀況
其實不只只有CoreWars
還有第二個叫做這個SORIC
這個系統整合的這單晶片
甚至再把CPU整合進來
因為台積電的藍圖是做Cube
是說我稍微科普一下
GPU旁邊排8個HBL
這個叫做這個2.5D CoAWS
本身自己GPU或AC可邏輯的堆疊
這個叫S-O-IC
在整個晶片上面再放CPU進來
會是整個大完整的拼圖
這個東西都還在走
還在做大爆發
所以大家不要擔心
但把半導體的一個狀況
那資本支度增加
我想大家也就知道
那從CoAX裡面
還有一個FANOUT的PENAL LEVEL
就是說原本是用原型的
細菌原或者是CAREY
那換成PENAL
那換成面板呢
其實大家很簡單
我簡單畫一個圓就知道
你切割成金曆
不管你怎麼切
你邊邊的都不能用
這個是這個所謂邊角料
可是如果你是正方形
過長方形
你的這個產能利用率
經歷的狀況就增加很多
OK
那整個半導體的黃金年代
這個訓練道推理
還有這個卡哥瑞
這個4384億的
整個半導體的一個產值
這25%了
不要說黃金年代
真的就30年沒有見過
是30年沒有見過的
那我們當然來看
哪一些股票是受惠的
那當然先從台積電來看
那資本支出增加
美國繳出漂亮的成績單
然後這個盲率率很高
這個部分我想
大家也都對台積電不陌生
那另外我等一下會補充就是說
英特爾之前股價是20幾
那從20幾以來呢
其實在美國政府入主
還有輝達入主之後
英特爾漲到100多
那整個所有Pending的案子都重啟
所以剛剛趙華講得很明白
就是說以前英特爾是股價
去年是25年新低
然後季辛格又走
可是福布奇的阿島
現在英特爾是這個全世界
都覺得他是好棒棒的一個
而且美國政府的support time
還有一個美國的半導體的領頭洋
我們台灣其實很多雙跨的
最後會講到
那萬一效果了這些設備股
其實我們就稍微點名幾個
其實跟COAS相關的
就是軍華智盛的集團
OK 這個是
萬潤也跟Coward是有關
那這個智盛還有這個加分
那我們稍微來看一下
其實最近表現其實也都算是還不錯
先看萬潤
創新高就最強
長最多就是主流
疊比人家少
例如說有些什麼聖誕樹的
助公園
我們有講誰
聖誕樹是有
我們有介紹過幾個聖誕樹
我們是忠實觀眾
對不對
被割韭菜割泡菜之後
1400 跌到700
就是腰斬
或腳踝斬膝蓋斬
這個沒有
因為他之前在股災之前
在這邊橫盤整理
我們講股災嘛
7月多
他頂多之後1000多跌到800多
跌不到兩場是跟台積電一樣強的
他先跌了啦
對
先跌了
好
那也沒關係
其實說實話
這個現行就不是聖誕樹嘛
好我們用這個
那再來
他
漲破這個所謂的6月 7月的
歷史高嘛
沒錯
也許沒有過程前高
可是說實話相比於很多
一些比較元氣恢復比較慢的
不要再亂點名了
很多公司都是好公司
只是稍微孤職高了
那籌碼當然就比較亂
那我們來看
業績真的有底氣
今年以來
這個營收累積成長42
那7月跟6月的營收都是新高附近
大跳增
10億
那大跳增的原因就在於
他有這個CPO的設備
出道嘉義
那我不能說嘉義是誰
我也不能說龍頭廠是誰
但這個光偶設備是
法人最近看他
一個最新的亮點
所以除了coars原本以外
我覺得舊加新是更好的
那萬論做什麼呢
其實萬論很簡單
做這個邦頂點焦跟貼合
這一張我一直研究
我就說 貼合工藝機使
好像在做裝潢
要做裝潢 好
那我簡單說
你晶片其實是很微小耐米的
那貼的上面要有膠
所以如果你膠太多貼進去會溢膠
那出來旁邊都是晶片
那就完蛋
因為那個影響很大
可能每一顆晶片其實這個都很貴
貼太少了
掉了
對 黏不出
不錯 很厲害
所以很簡單
如果從方道圓貼的要更多
材料不一樣
那它的技術
它有一個很特殊的技術
所謂的這個
連續的熱帳冷縮的圍圖塊的技術
敏感度等等
這個是他原本就蠻厲害
這是Copos
那當然啦
因為Copos爆單嘛
這個造法已經這個開門建山了
所以他整個產能
其實台積電的Copos跟Copos是
Unscange一直在加
7萬片10萬片13萬片18萬片
那除了這個再加了Copos
大概是三個題材
那第三個當然就是CPU嘛
那Copos其實就是說
裡面積變大
那簡單說貼的就要變多嘛
那原本是同樣的細的嘛
那現在做了玻璃
這個比較難
是
這個叫close loop
叫做動態避回入微力控
好啦 就是力氣很難控制啦
喔
這個力氣要輕輕點
微力控
對 力氣的控制就是說
你不能太大力
又不能太小力
對 是這樣沒錯
簡單說是這樣啦
但是這個其實他們有enounce
就是說
因為其實這不是我們想的
那麼簡單
沒錯
絕對不是那麼簡單
那當然這個是萬論
那當然CPU就是說
台積電把光子整進去了
做co-package
那他已經因為
我們只能說都是傳說
傳6月7月
台積電已經在某一些
應該是說台灣的龍頭廠
在某一些這個CPU裡面
他在加大力度
那出他設備
明年展望聽說
一個光影型要8個CPU
這個模組
那他的設備其實貢獻
貢獻其實就蠻多的
這是光偶盒
這是萬論的市場的題材
那軍華的部分呢
其實軍華今年獲利是四五塊
因為第二季財報比較差一點
所以前一陣也是先跌
他跌的就蠻深的
這高跌做差有點深
這個就不屬於創新料就是最強
漲最多就是主流
所以我兩頁就帶過他
沒有
兩頁也不少
他也是頭監禮打得不錯
是
真的耶
隊長
頭子 肯定
認真剛剛現場講到認真聽
左肩右肩
這也是準備整理
但我必須說
他真的是有三角收斂
他不是因為去槓桿
因為他本來是孤子太高
他不是那種聖誕樹
因為你自己
你去看到那個營收
5塊 4塊
他今年法人孤30 明年50
其實獲利很好
對 獲利不錯
可是60倍本益比
沒錯
1800出去30
那我自己不會在60倍本益比獎
那我們在20倍本益比獎
然後又有法人認為
第一個Covas受惠
那這個Apple
tool了這個WMCM的這個封裝
那其實萬變不如其中
不管在哪裡做先進封裝
其實你最好的選擇只有台積電
那當然說Intel也有做Emerber
但是那個產能還是
接台積電和盛的
我們沒有翻譯成英文的節目
所以就是他們都結台積電
吃肉 喝湯剩下滴出來的
但原則上
英特爾也是可靜的對手
技術師還OK
我們這都會幫您特別翻譯
好 謝謝趕快彭博社來採訪我們
但我講的就是產業的現況
你說整個Covas先進封裝
是讓整個台積電
再次超越對手的一個厲害的武器
那軍華其實在這個呆邦的
其實也是跟這個貼合機
年經機有點相關
這個部分前中後段都會用到
那因為已經先疊
那其實呢
整個這個
剛剛講的SOIC
就是這個概念就是這樣
它是原本的ASIC晶片再堆疊
所以除了HBM可以堆疊
那邏輯晶片也可以堆疊
所以今年其實蠻多設備
大家已經不講Cowas
因為這個是舊屏
用SOIC跟CPU
但這的確都是台積電在發展的事情
大概是這個樣子
所以聽起來他也蠻棒的
因為他也回到合理估值
對 但是我必須說
以他的現行跟他這個財報
還是有一點小弱
比如說萬論營收在爆
然後有CPO
那軍華有CPO
大家好像也不太知道
那軍華有那個
我說S.O.I.C
大家一直覺得他就是COVAX
然後一直覺得他已經被炒作過了
所以他有一些先天上的優
你不能說他不好
因為他漲到1800多過
那其實這個東西就是
大家要從整個從網面跟技術線
綜合來看
最後這個三分鐘壓箱寶
壓箱寶
這個前一陣子CB發行
轉換價在476
一直沒跌破
是
對 終於被我等到了
被你等到一個股災
股災
這個股災快速站回來
所以原則上我認為
它就是一個橫盤整理
是
整理在CB
因為它5月發
那三個月才可以轉換
所以壓三個月
因為創高發CB拉高定價
整理三個月
這是我的祕密武器
因為現在剛好就在CB這個價格
所以回到這478
整個8月20幾號開始可以轉化
OK 那當然你買在這個定價下面
算是安全
再來營收創歷史新高
7月營收充起來了
是的 然後呢
獲利創歷史新高
那加登了我們簡單來看一下
再回來這個營收
他其實是全球晶圓載具的
這個EUEPAD
EUEPAD的士戰率的龍頭
只有他跟INTEL
所以是寡戰
可是INTEL以前跌到25年新低
所以現在他第二支角好了
所以INTEL所有的案子都重啟
加等等於是復活了
那第二個他做這個所謂光照傳送盒
這個光照傳送盒就有記憶體跟成熟製程
那他去年有一些大陸的一個
因為去年成熟智能比較差
所以他三隻腳
除了先進製程的EUV
然後Intel回來了
然後成熟智能跟記憶體也回來
那又是寡戰
營收貨利用創立值新高
我覺得目前
除了股信比較差以外
我看不到他有任何產業上
還有基本面上的雜音
所以這個是EUV PAD
那晶圓載具這個FOOP
是做成熟製程
裝晶圓的
晶圓是一片一片裝在這裡
所以例如說像海利市
他要來台積電做3D堆疊
下面的Best代
他就用這個裝
他的HBN裝過來
台積電幫他做完
甚至連美國亞利桑那也是這個裝過來
因為美國還沒有先進製程
所以這個東西
其實都跟家燈有關係
那最後我們回到這一頁
其實家燈的一個現行
在這邊回到468
然後營收獲利創新高
又加上整個產業寡賬
我覺得他是一個很棒的未來
這個業績很好的一個這個公司
所以9月的展你會親自過去看
當然 其實在南港而已
去登記一下就可以去
歡迎大家一起來
也會比較著重在先進製程
先進風裝的這一塊做觀察
這邊非常謝謝隊長
隊長講產業真的非常生動
剛剛講說年要剛剛好
真的你想想看
你的手機換保護貼
你自己年都一堆氣泡
更何況是年金元
這麼樣精密跟高價的東西
所以相關的技術
在所謂的先進風路裡面
真的是很重要
而股價當然率先已經上來
而且7月營收開始暴衝的
這是隊長覺得最重視的
剛剛陸續介紹了幾家公司
他家鄉保就是可以雙吃的
Intel就算要加入不加入
他都有Intel的訂單
而且有寡占高的市占率
這件事情是很重要的
不管台股要打幾隻腳
至少三隻腳都在的時候
未來的營運發展就值得期待
今天非常謝謝三位的朋友
來到現場
雖然今天交通比較冷清
但是來賓討論得很樂利
因為台股的產業
真的非常的多樣性
也具急劇發展性
那也希望今天
李台達安秀對您投資有幫助
明天再會了
拜拜